bonjour marie hélène mart dit sur elie
bonjour aux éditeurs de martinique la
première alors vous êtes candidate aux
élections législatives sur la
circonscription du centre atlantique sur
la liste de combat ouvrier pourquoi
qu'est ce qui motive cette candidature
eh bien je m'appelle mallet les noirs
dit super liger 59 ans je travaille dans
la production agricole la banane est mon
suppléant et steve ciseaux un jeune
travailleur de 27 ans qui travaille dans
la restauration rapide je me présente à
ces élections sous l'étiquette de combat
ouvrier lutte ouvrière a fait de
présenter nos
nos idées alors justement on y vient
concernant le territoire martinique dans
sa globalité quels sont les dossiers
prioritaires que vous souhaitez défendre
si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale
eh bien
il n'y dossiers à défendre
premièrement
en loi contre les licenciements
contre la hausse des prix
contre le chômage et aussi pour la
pauvreté
pour permettre que - peut vivre
correctement
signe des lois a fait c'est adam
s'installa parce qu'un look away ne
serait ce que des lois qu'ils la
équipage chez me paie appliquée ballet
travailler
allons-nous cadic déjà fait appliquer
des lois qu'ils a existé de publier
longtemps que les travaillait pas qu'à
bénéficier que yo pa ka appliquée du
tout eh bien nous nous qui y travaillent
a fait 6 et puis éventuellement sennour
uv et lui les quatre députés qui est
l'ouvrier au combat ouvrier qu'à
présenter faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs sinon river est élu ça veut
dire qu'en ayant conscience des
travaillait qui changé et que yo envie
qu'eux
nous soit porte-parole you pour que
demain parce que faut pas oublier que
nous nous les criées en partie en parti
communiste révolutionnaire paucod
ouvriers ni en partie du cône est quand
et pour l'oeil cap à l'est et du
bouledogue la police alors ici on parle
maintenant plus globalement de la
circonscription dans laquelle vous vous
présentez dans le centre atlantique
pensez vous qu'il y a des dossiers qui
sont urgents qui sont plus spécifiques à
cette circonscription est bien mais nous
nous fini nouveau fini digne a de a1 à
a2 en martinique qui sont 400 louis mais
ses souffrances oui mais ça important
parce que à la martinique qui sont
catane ses souffrances ses pauvreté ces
licenciements
c'est cet hymne ces jeunesses la kippa
qu'arriver trouvait placé aux
exemples campus la proviseure 19 là il
faut que les jeunes aient crié que yo ka
souffrait yo pa ni moyenne
pourrions-nous rico yo yo pa ni moyer
puyo payer il nie baghai pou fé
handident dit d'appuyer ne serait ce que
comme tu as fini d'y commencer par
mettez en place des lois contre les
licenciements content parce que nous n'y
en chômage qui est extrêmement important
local adonis et 4% de mangini 50 cent et
puis qui au chômage violet réformer la
retraite mais comme une hyène ou caf est
allé si c'est pas en lutte et en
mobilisation générale pour nous faire
les choses avancent et nous est capable
un mot c'est aussi en syndicaliste qui a
représenté les salariés agricoles
empoisonné par le chlordécone et
notamment par les pesticides dos tout me
semble que les ouvriers agricoles
travaillent dans de mauvaises conditions
et que in id loi qui quittent leur pour
les conditions de travail qui ne serait
ce que la sécurité sociale
c'est ensemble loi comment nyayo fait
appliquer et bien si tu réponds bah
c'est lui qui fait qu'elio appliquée
alors nous ni des harmonies des outils
là mais ne serait ce que pour faye est
appliquée est bien fourni lutte faut une
immobilisation derrière tout ça nous
qu'on fait parce que c'est un seul dans
ce territoire là que tout travail est à
points fait l'autre est ouvert à tous et
pourquoi ton en bidons gas 35 euros ils
paca concernés uniquement jean
fort-de-france il parlera concerne
uniquement genre est une vieille par a
concerné jean icart concerner tout le
monde l'est nou ka mandé que nous les
lignes au smic à 2000 euros c'est pour
permettre que les retraités peuvent
vivre convenablement pour permettre
réunis en allocation corps est pour
permettre connu un salaire c'est pour ça
vous commandez que et union smic à 2000
euros parce que vous condamnez comme
situation tellement
dévastatrices que ouvriers pas call
river pascal rivet joindre les deux
bouts le cap à l'est qu'à une longueur
du mot qu'elle ne voit pas les coeurs
ouvriers et bien lancée ouvriers qui
kabati riches et cela et c ur cu qui a
dans ces entreprises là qui panique au
3e etc pour ça le cas médicaux ni en
contrôle comme les ouvriers où il vait
fait en contrôlant dit dans ces
entreprises là pour permettre de sable
qui sa clique à passer parce que ces
messieurs cap warner là laurent et yoka
pâtit et pendant ce temps ou dans la
misère ou dans la pauvreté alors
brièvement avant de terminer
marie-hélène marques dites sur hellip ou
qu'avez vous à dire aux électeurs vous
pouvez vous adresser à eux directement
eh bien mon caddie les électeurs puisque
combat ouvrier lutte ouvrière qu'à
présenter les deux candidats d' à tout
l'ensemble martinique le cas dit que
voter bas combat ouvrier voter bas et le
tout brillant c'est voter voter bac
candidature nous c'est voter à dark
trois autres c'est voter bas travaillait
mondes qui l' épisode 14 souffrent aux
autres et on choisit quant aux autres le
camp des travailleurs le front des
travailleurs une arrivée au zoo du temps
merci à vous marier une marque dit sur
elie
[Musique]